Commissioner ho can you met this morning
here in Washington DC with the
counterparts from the United States and
Japan I understand that there is an
agreement to strengthen existing rules
on industrial subsidies and condemn
forced technology transfer practices can
you tell us a little bit more about this
well I'm very pleased that the European
Union the United States and Japan are
able to come to an agreement in respect
of our statement of intent to deal with
industrial subsidies and forced
technology transfer because we need a
level playing field for all of our
companies in order to be able to trade
locally and regrettably we don't have
this restricted level playing field
presently some countries are flowering
the rules and disciplines that are in
the WTO process at the moment so we have
to revise our rules to take account of
the fact that the WTO rules have not
been changed for 25 years and we have to
adapt those rules to the modern
industrial and trading environment that
we have at the moment so ambassador
light hyzer and minister kagiyama from
japan and myself were very pleased to be
able to advance this work and build on
the progress that was made by the
Minister for Trade mentor Sachi and
Commissioner Malmstrom over the last
number of months Commission you have a
very busy schedule here in Washington DC
these days and you'll be meeting with
members of Congress and meaning a
meeting with members of the US
administration what is your message to
the Americans well I want to see the
United States and European Union
resetting its relationship and to
developing a positive and common trade
agenda we have an enormous amount of
work to do we agree on many things but
we haven't really developed a structural
dialogue in relation to these issues in
a positive way in the last number of
years so I hope that ambassador
lighthouse or an i and other
interlocutors that we'll be meeting in
the United States here this week will be
able to agree with us that we have more
in common and then perhaps we realize
and that we want to engage in
cooperation and dialogue rather than in
confrontation in relation to matters
that are before us and in dispute at the
moment so we setting and refreshing the
relationship and developing a positive
agenda around trade is the objective of
the visit
great Thank You commissioner